70% des jeunes filles françaises 62 %
des garçons croire au grand amour c'est
l'un des résultats du sondage csa le
parisien libéré antenne 2 à partir de
demain et toute la semaine danser la vie
à 18h30
catherine ceylac et bruno gex vous
proposeront une série de témoignages et
de reportages sur ce thème des jeunes et
de l'amour les premiers rapports sexuels
le mariage la virginité les jeunes
répondent très franchement à toutes ces
questions ce soir je vous propose un
double témoignage recueilli par bruno
gex deux jeunes qui parlent de leurs
rapports et de leur avenir
je pense que ça c'est pas ça c'est
cynique
moi je trouve ouais ben ouais c'est ce
qu'avance physique
bon on a quand même des relations
sexuelles assez fréquentes par rapport à
la plupart des jeunes qu'on connaît et
disons c'est peut-être ça aussi un sens
mais il ya autre chose aussi si c'est
dur à définir on a aussi je pense a des
liens d'amitié assez profond y a pas de
complexe
rapports hommes/femmes nantes sur ses
gardes
resté mystérieux il n'y a pas de ça
entre nous c'est ces francs on rigole
comme si on était amis c'est la part de
sentiments amoureux de niro moi je le
vois pas pour l'instant avec quelqu'un
je vois plutôt je vois plutôt en
l'avenir professionnel pas projet pense
à ça que je pense du manceau non parce
que ce que tu es là je vis au jour le
jour
j'aime bien faire des projets mais je me
fixe est pas là dessus
moi pour l'instant mon avenir c'est le
bac
et puis après c'est après ce film je
pense